today i want to talk to you about your
daily monitoring activities and how big
of an impact that has
in a life of a startup entrepreneur
i'm patrick with your host of
valuetainment weekly and today i want to
talk to you about your daily monitoring
activities let me explain to you what
this is
so think about the person you know who's
very successful in business
and life as an entrepreneur running a
day-to-day business and
and you could think about an uncle or
friend or relative or somebody you know
of
and you've met them before and you
wonder why do they do so well in
business and you say
but i'm better than them in this and i'm
and i'm better than them in this but um
but i'm better than them
and you look at all these things but i'm
better than them but there's one thing
you don't know about if you're better
than them and you know what it is
it's the daily monitoring activities you
see
i've met entrepreneurs and successful
business people who are very tall who
are very short
who are in shape who are not in the best
of shape
who are white hispanic asian doesn't
matter speak good english speak don't
speak good english
they're very good communicators they're
not good community i've met them all
and you wonder how did this person make
it because
very little of it has to do with what
you see on the outside
most of it has to do with what they do
when you don't see and that comes down
to their daily monitoring activity let
me talk to you
about what the daily monitoring activity
could be activity could be a couple
things to keep in mind for instance
most of the time they carry a gym bag in
their cars
why somehow someway they're going to
find a way to exercise
three to five times a week they figure
out a way to exercise
three to five times a week to keep their
brain fresh to keep them sharp
to keep them going to keep their
intensity high to keep them in shape so
they're not slow and lethargic
to keep them driven it could be a daily
monitor an activity of sending five
cards every day no matter what they do
but you never see it
it could be a daily monitoring activity
of sending a gift per day
of doing a favor for a restaurant per
day
it could be a daily monitoring activity
of going and giving a gift to a waitress
or some place
per day that no one sees it could be a
daily monitoring activity that they
themselves every day
are going to do make 50 calls make 100
cars calls make 200 calls
prospect 5 people whatever it could be
but they have
very very specific daily monitoring
activities that they do no matter what
and typically successful people
they're kind of like a think about a
character
where they go to a restaurant they sit
in the same place
they have the same routine they don't
change a lot of things up they keep
doing the same thing
they don't get bored by same activities
you would be amazed how a lot of the
most successful people in the world
they don't get bored with the same
things they keep doing it while
a lot of times sometimes people who are
very creative and they can get a lot of
distractions
they they use their creativity in the
wrong way of constantly feeling like
they have to
have to do this i have to do that i have
to do this and they don't allow enough
momentum to get them going to the next
level
while the successful guys like every now
i'm doing this i've been doing the same
thing for the last 15 years
i sent the same restaurant i sent the
same place it's the same church that's
in the same
way i ordered it's a lot of consistency
that very few people see so you may say
oh my goodness how do i create new
daily monitoring activities do you know
how many daily monitoring activities you
yourself have that you don't even know
about think about that for a moment
who needs to tell you about brushing
your teeth every day how long does it
take
who needs to tell you about showering
every day how long does that take who
needs to tell you about doing your
makeup doing your hair putting on
clothes ironing
washing clothes filling up your gas tank
driving your car the way you do the way
you exit the freeway you take
the routine you take the books you read
the prayers you do
the things you do with your kids family
it doesn't tv
shows some of them are not good daily
monitoring activities but i promise you
if you were
to write down what do i do every single
day
you would come up with a list of 100
minimum activities
that you do every single day and in
order to be successful in business you
know what you just need to do you just
need to add
five new daily monitoring activities and
drop
five of them that don't do you well that
don't do your service on a daily basis
replace five that don't do your service
with five that do your service
and you will be amazed on what happens
with your business but it could take
three six
twelve months because whatever change
you make today you will not see for 90
days to six months
and if you do that all of a sudden six
months 12 months later
two years later three years later five
years later you'll start hearing people
telling you
you know he got so lucky in business he
got so lucky in this you know he's such
a lucky guy but the reality is
you just have more efficient daily
monitoring
activity than they do that's really what
it comes down to
that nobody else sees and eventually
success is on your side
it's my message of the week to him
please be sure to
click on the website on the bottom go to
patrickbetdavid.com
and subscribe to my weekly newsletters
what they do unders what are you doing
are you trying to get some bloopers is
that what because i was on a roll and
you're sitting there playing with the
camera
when you see somebody who's successful
and is doing very very well
see my wife coming in do you guys want
to be in a valuetainment episode come
say hello to everybody here say hello
everybody here's
my good friend morale we just went to
her wedding
this is my wife jennifer if you haven't
seen her valuetainment
and this is the man behind the camera
you rarely see who confuses me half the
time and throws me off and distracts me
half the time but it wouldn't be the
same videos
without this guy hello hello